hello welcome to the lobby gamespot's
weekly hang out every tuesday at two
p.m. pacific right here on gamespot com
i'm your host on you are how you doing
we have a show this week we weren't
gonna have a show this week we did that
whole thing it packs last week all the
packs people saw their like that's great
we saw a live you're gonna broadcast on
Tuesday right kinda we're gonna have all
that stuff on the side but we decided
there's so much stuff to talk about why
not have another lobby so today we're
gonna talk about Mad Max we're gonna
talk about Metal Gear Solid 5 first of
all I me baman Robert handlery you guys
are here to tell me all about a game
that you guys saw at PAX which I know
kevin van noord loved at e3 a lot of
buzz around it at the moment tell me
what's so good about dreadnought Rob
what it's so good about dreadknot is
that spaceship it's okay it's the
slow-moving spaceship that when you
should when you look at it the gameplay
wise it doesn't look that fast pace but
the cool thing is is that there's
actually so much to do as far as
managing your energy and ship abilities
and powered by options that it just
really creates this high energy high
suspenseful kind of mobile field of a
map right it's weird because yeah like
you guys are coming back saying this is
super fun to play kevin said at e3 it
was one of the best demos he's had it's
exactly to your point it's the type of
game that I over gameplay doesn't look
super exciting because it's so laborious
and slow and whatnot but you're saying
like the moment-to-moment action there's
like your kind of managing a lot while
even if the looks like there's not a lot
going on right right so there's like two
things that you're constantly doing as
far as control why so right here you see
your power abilities on top but the main
thing is you got this power management
where you're basically putting into
three things there's there's a example
there where i imagining it and i'm
putting into shield what I know that my
health is going down time to throw on
shields when I'm on a tack course thrown
into power why are your weapons so it's
kind of like a leash or self stuff like
that but I guess the big difference is
that those games are like dog fighting
games right yes dreadnought is an online
team based game where you're you're not
look how slow this thing's moving your
kind of thing like we're really big
ships right really big ships and you
if you're not into the slow-moving ones
you get your kind of like quick and
nimble Millennium Falcon that does more
hidden run type stuff you know obviously
you have lower health so you get the
idea is you go in you go out and you're
constantly moving around and then here
you have your huge Jesus loking you know
dreadknots that have you know really
awesome like like this some of them have
like nukes we're like you fire a nuke
and then you can remote detonate it and
it just does like insane amount of
damage um but yeah there's just so many
cool abilities and you know I sought a
year ago and it was you know it's fun
but now they're doing these things where
it's like there's a new Gretchen it just
right oh yeah it just Nile eights you so
here's my favorite so this guy right
here oh man and it was so cool and they
did this so this is a plasma ram so
watch you yeah throwing shields and then
you gauge your plasma Ram right here and
you just Ram these dudes it's so
freaking wait sites that's like that's
like you literally ramming into people
with that thing yeah and it just like
the smaller ships are just they're done
and then here's another move coming up
and I by the way had the devs next to me
and they're kind of guiding me and
there's two these guys yelling I me
because you have to line up the ship you
have to charge it up and someone will
see it from a mile away but here it goes
boom Oh George it's you know there's
slow-moving ships so it's like there's
such a suspense and an amount of tension
like trying to get to a guy and using it
is it like a pleasure in knowing that
that one shot like Enterprise thought
just killed about 500 anything like blue
suits or whatever it exactly immediately
uh um so here's here's another moment
yeah there's a new guy fire here you
remote detonate it but then you get cool
things to where you know you say I'm I'm
dying and I need help so I talked my
teammate I say I need help they need
help he can teleport in as a power
ability and then assist me on the flip
another guy it's a I'm attacking a guy
he's about to teleport cuz it's kind of
like a warm-up period yeah I can throw
down like a disruptor ability to stop
him from warping cool um and so there's
there's a lot of management in your
abilities can i roll that back second
you saying is a medic ship yes there's a
guy this is a dead it's like I'm just
gonna like basically help you out
here so now I'm warping to get closer to
a guy because he had lower hell no whoa
um yeah there's a medic ship there's
like a sniper class you know those guys
kind of lurk around the sides and maps
and um sniper ships yeah this is weird
because this is so the last game I'd
like I lovely dangerous in all of those
games but that what this is sort of
reminiscent of is is star wars
battlefront when I played that mode
where you were it was like thai fighter
vs x-wing basically yeah where's the
arghast of you know rubbers versus the
[ __ ] whatever [ __ ] star wars and but
that's like a dog fighting simulator
right so that's like you're speeding
around you're dying really quickly a
respawn and you can really quickly
they've got kind of like they've got
loads of like creep almost which are
worth less points which are a I will try
to come this kind of feels this looks a
lot more like something like World of
Tanks where you're working a totally
like a team your lives kind of matter
like what's the sort of turnover and
like time to die and how long are the
games what's the pace of it yeah there's
like you know two 10-minute games here's
actually this is a new game oh they show
it off where it's like last man standing
but instead of spectating the rest of
the match you get to pilot these really
maneuverable you just keep spawning
these guys but the idea behind this
which is so cool is I die there's say I
got my like last teammate who's actually
flying around and my whole team is are
these little fighters you have to
communicate with these guys and take on
the other enemies in that you have
really you know low firepower but when
you all inter spite of you work together
and work together you can take other
guys down it's like yeah what was the
game where you respawn as a pigeon when
you died it was the it was ARMA right it
was not armed line or something they did
that Andy what is it you like about
dreadknots so question Daniel tip so
it's like five on five right yeah I've
been easy to jump in its got like Crysis
style like maximum armor maximum women
so it's really fast to select which is
awesome because you imagine if you're
actually at the helm of one of these
ships um talking about like elite
dangerous that's kind of like cumbersome
she like yeah where am I sit down my man
engines but I got all his momentum it's
like oh I gotta like shoot but I got a
power up my weapons and wait and it's
like wait for the lock-up have a total
of manuals like
Malaysian yeah whereas this takes all
that's awesome about piloting a ship
like Blazers and [ __ ] rockets
swarming everywhere and then like plasma
things and heels sure and warping and
ramming and it's like it puts it all
immediately available to you in a in a
battle arena where there's verdict out
like you know you're not just going at
each other on a map you're flying and
maneuvering and you hang out to recover
there's like little floating space
stations and [ __ ] like that speaking of
the sniper like you were you know that
was my favorite class yeah cuz I would
go like way far on the edges and like go
through these d'bries of like asteroid
mining facilities or whatever they are
and just like take these really long
shots at these ships and they were like
did devastating damage but you know I
take like one shot dead right it was
really cool to like balance that out
where you know you got all these games
like these first-person shooters coming
out like law breakers it's just
announced yeah overwatch is gonna be
great battle born battle born this is
like that but its ships man you jump
right in but you're doing huge
Battlestar Galactica like era esque like
ships and it was so it was kind of what
you're saying is that she needs me to
pick up as a voice like most space
shooty strategy games are kind of a
little bit cobras play around it's just
like a shooter but it's but it's
spaceships which is like that's pretty
cool oh yeah like World of Tanks you're
saying that's a good and it's another
free to play pc game which this is
they're not saying it's coming to
consoles yeah it probably is they
probably haven't got that self signed
yet so I guess to that end did it feel
free to play in that like the sort of
the hook with those games often is that
like they are very repeatable the rage
fun yeah we're kind of chasing a carrot
as well so are you unlocking different
ships you're unlucky in different modes
and we lucky different like aspects to
your ships and right so stuff uh so
there are different classes of ships the
idea is that like if I focus on one
class I can kind of unlock other ships
but the another thing they showed off
which we couldn't show was now you're
able to take a ship and customize the
hell out of it so it's like a control
tower you know you see in like a Star
Destroyer screw that I want that take it
out choose like five options of a
another type of control tower like by
the end of it your ship looks completely
different and then that's not even
bringing like you know paint jobs
different types
buildings like nukes you can you know
throw on and those have really cool
that's like God weapons and stuff like
that as well yeah so that's where you
going for and that's what they said you
know it's not really clear whether
that's like a where the payment goes in
but they said it's going to be a very
horizontal progression as far as I'm
walking cool yeah well I guess final
question I'm kind of interested in this
for a bunch of reasons that one of them
is that this is being developed by
Yeager who are the folks who made spec
ops the line which is the type of
there's no white phosphorus no it's okay
like really she's a lien mini-game
having a lot of no maybe yeah there they
kind of took third person shooters and
they that they made something very sort
of unique I'm not guessing there's gonna
be the narrative through line that that
game have and read not but it did it
stand out for any other reasons is it
just like there's a feel like a like a
good balance between simulation on our
Cade like what is the sort of core thing
that you really enjoyed about playing
dreadnought that like made you want to
come on and speak volumes about it it
just remember I'm a huge spaceship guy
like I just anything that has spaceships
flying around sci-fi elements I'm sold
it's so sorry about what I said about
Star Wars it's all right but what is so
great about this game is you get so much
of that visually audio wise you know
just laying you know you know
broadsiding another ship and just like
all power like make it make a risk like
man my health is a little Oh screw it
I'm putting everything into power I'm
gonna take this guy out I'm gonna flee
it just feels very strategic in that way
and again I'm only playing by myself but
what I really gather was like man if
like I had some buddies with me who are
helping me out with some port sniping
talking to your other you nobody's is
gonna make this game really fun too yeah
because the ships aren't easy to kill
they're actually like they take a
beating especially if you're good at
managing there's a healer or your doing
your shields so you do have to like
focus buyer and you the coordination is
cool because it's like an admiral taking
this fleet you know how like ship naval
combat in for example Black Flag is kind
of like really boring I'll just like
hold down thing shoot some cannons and
then they run away like and that can
happen in space games too right but this
it's more like a shooter it's like
totally Arkady but also like you feel
like you're
to accomplishing something that took
like naval flight academy style yeah
like the digit ratita kills are
satisfying reason cookie bunk at last
questions can you hear the explosions in
space see I was thinking the map i was
on was in atmosphere okay i could I saw
space levels could you hear the
explosions hey don't do this was it
silent no is actually sound in space i
heard but like like your eyes are closed
it is always sound and spice ever i was
really something he's just so different
yeah we'll see about that general thank
you so much for coming on and telling us
all about dreadnought if you've seen
dreadknot a few play space games please
let us know what you thought I bet our
coverage of dread out of packs and III
as well previously in the comment box
below Oh sexy oh it's hot down there
I've got a bunch more stuff to talk
about today oh my goodness the trailers
there they're everywhere moted forts
motorsport 6 we put a prepared on the
side only a couple of late that days ago
demos out today if you wish and we've
got a trainer furnish what yeah now yep
you weren't mad in focus
we
wickham every
we're gonna be free
ok
I'll take
I said
get the xbox one limited edition bundle
this week we see the launch are one of
the most anticipated open-world video
games of recent memory and also mad max
hi peter brian hey doing good nice a
soft love for you yeah gamespot's very
own Chum Bucket how you doing my friend
the hell does that mean I know harpoons
and publishers who put out games I don't
love sure or love or you just come to
work I'm not wearing any clothes
disheveled and just hand over to getting
shirts on me yeah nah thanks to sure do
tell me about doom ask me about do know
uh yeah look people seem to think I hate
mad max I don't there are parts about it
I really like that world looks amazing
apart from a few framerate issues which
I'm pretty sure will be patched out the
game just is rendered so well and when
you're driving which is one of the best
parts of the game when terms of gameplay
things are moving so fast and the action
is so hectic and you have a lot of tools
at your disposal and you feel you feel
like you're participating in a Mad Max
film you know you get the sense that
like there's this movement and speed and
chaos and grit and grease you're right
in the middle of it and that's awesome
so what is it that doesn't work there
are a few things that don't work I'm
going to start with I think the most
obvious thing that's on the screen right
now is the hand in hand combat
regardless of the game Mad Max has not
known as a character to get into fist
fights but this combat doesn't really
seem suited to the game either a lot of
pension tension was paid to car combat
and that is definitely the most exciting
but then you have to go do these things
where you're you're fighting enemies and
the combat system is very reminiscent of
something you'd find from other Warner
Brothers games like Batman or middle
earth shadow of Mordor where you know
you mash an attack button and enemy has
an icon above their head when they're
going to attack you either a Vader block
this is a very simple system that while
I think many people accept it and that's
fine and maybe they enjoy it I don't
because for me if I can
exploit it by literally sitting there
and tapping my fingers like this yeah to
win a battle there's no challenge I'm
not being rewarded or making good use of
my time yeah and i think the nuance of
that is lost on some people where I
remember like when you told me that and
you were like literally saying you don't
even need to look at the screen you're
just tapping it and there was like
videos before of like how in shadow of
Mordor that same thing was the case but
that was with like a high spec character
who are like very specific things
unlocked this is like right at the gate
the combat has just never really gets
any better than that no I mean you do
you unlock new skills for max but you
don't really have much control over them
they're just more contextual things that
happen when an enemy is say to your
right or your left but you're just
pressing square and they just happen to
be there at some point you know an enemy
will throw an unblockable move your way
but then you just tap the right shoulder
button and you're safe and you can go
back to doing what you were doing and I
don't think an extra variable that calls
for one button like twice in a fight
really makes the combat that much more
interesting it's as I said my review
it's too simple and dumb down and it
doesn't add anything to the experience
it just feels like a waste of time and
it's like something there to pad out the
game it sounds like it's just a lot of
like boring stuff you need to get
through sure I tell me about the like
missions themselves the quest is there
are they interesting is the the sort of
core like loop of what you're doing in
the game is that fun so you spent a lot
of time driving around the map getting
from one location to another typically
to take down a camp or remove like
sniper posts or something and the the
reason you're doing this is because
you've made an agreement with the chief
who sort of running the region that
you're in and you're trying to lower the
threat from enemies against them and so
by doing that they then agree to help
you get a new part for your car this
story is driven by I need a new muffler
I need a new engine you got to get that
grill man like that is seriously every
story beat is that you're trying to
build this car the magnum opus yeah and
the game requires you to have certain
things there was an early mission in the
game where you had to have these
specific parts before I got there I had
unlocked better stuff oh my god on my
car but I couldn't continue the mission
until I downgraded to these parts so is
this weird sort of function of forcing
you to get parts for your car by making
you play some pretty boring stuff and a
lot of that is going into camps and
doing like fist fights with guys and
basically clearing the camp alright
and and when you're doing those
activities you're collecting resources
such as scrap and maybe you want to save
this part for the question and answer
but I'm happy to talk about my issue
with scrap right now if you like yeah
actually yeah there's if I didn't pick
out one specific but like one of the
things that people were there's a couple
of there's a couple of like sore points
that people have actually interestingly
enough and we were talking about this
before people thought that you were
being too picky whereas actually the
criticisms of your review seem to be
very picky in their own right one of
them being that like the fact that you
the inventory system seems a bit
cumbersome or that you can carry too
much stuff so like yeah talk about that
so everything that you purchase you
purchased with scrap which is basically
shorthand for metal that you collect
around the world and no not any metal
it's not like you can just say hey no
one's using that fence I'm gonna take
that and trade it in you got to find
these little piles of scrap that's fine
you know whatever I can get past that
part because that's a little gamey thing
and gamey things exist in a lot of games
you know like such as The Witcher which
is someone pointed out to me like well
you can carry so much stuff in The
Witcher nobody complains not that much
well yeah I mean but the difference here
in Mad Max is that the world alone is a
world that's built on limitations and
how well equipped you are to overcome
those limitations and the game imposes
this notion on you by limiting the
amount of bullets you can carry Yeah
right things like that like forcing you
to get water you know to survive I mean
it is a game that tells you you need to
struggle for survival hmm but it also
tells you i need you to go out and
collect piles and piles and piles of
metal now you can carry even though you
can't carry a few more bullets yeah now
maybe I should have put that detail in
my review I realize I neglected to sort
of show a counterpoint what i was saying
which is why i think it's a problem
beyond it being inauthentic but it's
because the game tries so hard to sell
you on the world's authenticity and then
when it's convenient for the gameplay to
support this open-world structure it
doesn't matter anymore and if i'm trying
to buy into this story which i think
this is the story is more important to
this game than anything like the car
combat is great but really you're
motivated by the events at hand yeah I
want to believe in the world if you're
going to spend all this time in them
yeah so if I want to believe in the
world and the game is imposing
limitations on me to make me believe in
it but then throws those away when it
makes sense for itself that's when I
have a problem I don't have a problem
with games that are steeped in fantasy
and never
or try to address the fact that you know
everything must be logical but this game
tries so hard to put logic behind
everything except when it it's
convenient it's inconvenient for the
game man I got a bunch of questions here
then add to that point Johnny Webster
asked via Twitter what's the ratio of
time spent on foot as opposed to in car
thanks dude yeah you spend a lot of time
in your car there is the option to fast
travel which i think is [ __ ] in a
Mad Max game hmm because this is all
about traveling from one point to
another you know finding opportunities
of discovery both good and bad and so
too fast travel is sort of negating the
danger and threat of existing in this
world anyway back to the point you you
drive quite a lot the on foot stuff is
really only when you get to a base and
to get there you have to drive so there
is a lot of great stuff that that's
where you're in a car and I really
enjoyed those moments again like Mad Max
is a great game when it comes to driving
I may not have excellent controls
necessarily but the action and this sort
of the thrill you get is definitely
there yeah I got that when i played
someone gamescom but then when i had to
go in and actually care at a base i
thought okay this is a bit cumbersome
and boring and but one of the things i
found particularly out of bed when
you're talking about the car combat
because so much of it involves like
using cars to kill people is the fact
that Max is able to take a hit from a
car oh yeah like a hundred miles Marin
doesn't hurt oh yeah yeah so I can go
into a base and get in a fight with some
dudes and and before I realized how
exploitable the system was I was trying
to play along with it right like do what
it wanted me to do and I notice okay I
got hit hit a couple times and all of a
sudden was like wait I just died from
like that third guy hitting me hmm I
remember getting run over by a car
repeatedly and being fine you can get
hit by a car and you lose about a tenth
of your health and granted may can do
this to you can do miss you flips all
day long off you time your jump properly
understand them you can't stand in fire
the rules of this game are so I don't
wait not that far not but not every fire
that's the thing the game doesn't teach
you what technically it's it's silly
like the I don't I don't know how you
can justify any say well it's a video
game dude it's like yes I guess I get
that the video games have rules elements
like that remind me of like you can very
easily if you were a fan of this game
just ignore that stuff and it won't
bother you or as if you're not in the
position to do that if you're not
feeling like that it's justifiable that
you can like not carry weapons when you
can carry all this [ __ ] or that you can
hit by a car but get killed by three
punches like that's going to be [ __ ]
irritating especially the game isn't
entertaining which it sounds like it's
not it sounds like a lot of the missions
are laborious and there's a lot of them
to do there are a few where it sends you
to the sort of far-off corners of the
wasteland and you go underground and I
really do like those because you're
exploring things like a derelict airport
for example which is kind of interesting
you end up like walking through a huge
jetliner that's all broken down and
there are these like red-eyed enemies
that kind of scurry about in the shadows
and like I like that sense because it's
building the world but then you fight
him and it's the same old combat and
yeah it's you're literally just doing
fetch quests so you're going to clear
out a dungeon more or less as some folks
were giving out that there was some sort
of spoiler about the yeah ultimus ending
climactic fight perhaps okay maybe it's
not the fight i described comes towards
the end of the game it is not the final
conflict but I really have to ask people
if you're playing a Mad Max game which
is built around car combat and there is
a main antagonist do you not expect that
you're going to enter into car combat
with that antagonist I just want people
to think critically about this because
while I may have given away an element
that happened in the story if you were
surprised I'm sorry but but I imagine
that anyone who understands what this
game is and who the characters are that
that's not surprising and I didn't talk
about the story by the way I talked
about a battle that you get into I was
telling you earlier it's like you know
you play final fantasy 7 it's like
telling your buddy you fight sephiroth
he's like love fight saffron no no I'm
actually like everyone the officer
tested as I am the most irritating
person when it comes to spoilers like
it's like the amount of like times I've
been like that when people were talking
about innocuous details but until dawn
but I'm i have often like rallied to the
community when it comes to when there as
well kevin was a frequent spoiler or in
sweets and stuff all the [ __ ] time
and and sometimes in his reviews as well
but even I found out to just be a little
bit too much considering it's not
actually yes the ultimate ending of the
game yeah I mean I don't tell you the
outcome I don't all i do is say you
enter into car combat later in the game
with the main bad guy who knew I I'm
sorry yeah I'm a little bit disappointed
because it looked like my max has got
like it seems like it's sort of a by
number you know this looks like actually
it looks like the type of open world
game which it became at five years ago
probably would have been fine yeah but
we're graduated like this is the year
that the witcher 3 came back this year
the male ego solid the phantom pain
comes out and obviously we don't like
merit other games against other games
but like the goalpost change yes like
you know if a game like infamous was to
come here which just kind of you know
mirrors some aspects of it seems and
like we wouldn't address it the same way
in fact where we had Mike my Hardy on
the couch last week talking about gears
of war or Jeff christman on giant bomb
giving gears of war 12 out of 5 the game
that he adored like this is what happens
is that like what we expected these
types of games changes and and I guess I
can see why if some people have lower
expectations or they want to live a game
so much then they get particularly
Hirsch and when they when they see
critical assessments not landing where
they wanted them to yeah and i want to
say other outlets other reviewers gave a
lot of praise to Mad Max where I didn't
enjoy it and have a lower some in some
get it lower yeah you know I mean and
that's the nature of reviews I have my
own opinions and so do you out there and
like that's great I don't think we
should really be critical of each other
for having opinions and frankly my
opinion of this game is that it there's
too much stuff that is not developed
enough or thought out well enough to
make it that interesting and enjoyable
to play but the stuff that I do like the
car combat the world itself some of the
characters that's excellent and I think
if you have the time and you're
interested in the game that you should
play it for those things just expect
that it's not going to be all green
Peter Brad thank so much going on always
really appreciate it stick around we're
gonna talk to you a little bit about
other open world games above you
watching at home here live or via
YouTube gamespot and whatnot let us know
what you think of my max our view is up
on gamespot com you can go check it out
there and let us know if you're playing
the game while you think of it do you
agree or do you disagree stick in the
cards will be back in just a second I'm
gonna check out a trailer for the taken
king give me some more that Bungie money
that's it what they want that money get
that my getting that money give that
money back it's talking about to open
world games give me the money taken King
take my money
all actions have consequences and ours
have angered a god hey mom
he smells the blood of his son on our
hands
and now the taken king comes for us all
shaved in the cavalry
it is wrong to you know get destiny the
taken king and the complete destiny
adventure in the legendary edition
raditi 14 2015 has been a wonderful year
for video games many of whom have been
who which which probably way too deeply
about people many of which have been
open world video games we already have
the witcher 3 wild hunt earlier this
year of course Mad Max came it this week
as in Metal Gear Solid V the phantom
pain he has come to he hasn't got a
computer Brandon Justin hey walled here
at till have a little chinwag I bet I
guess what what makes a good open world
game and one of the things I'm
interested about is that argument here
last year midler chatter of Mordor a
fantastic game really enjoyed it last
year but I can already think of a
handful of oak more like this games this
year that have trumped it already like
open world games third-person ones
especially really come on and a long way
like far cry 4 GTA 5 like we're in a
sort of golden age for them at the
moment animal crossing I don't of course
right there yes codes so I guess someone
asks you guys and what it is bed Oh what
makes a good open ball game and where
the other games for thought Justin first
of all I think one of the ways that some
open world games really fail isn't
trying to give you so though I mean you
get either extreme you either get there
trying to do too much like here's a
world where there's just [ __ ] everywhere
Assassin's Creed 3 yeah a perfect
example of a beautiful world filled with
things to do you didn't ever want to do
it's like this is actually getting the
way of my enjoyment versus something
that's uh what was that rock star game
that had the great we found that
daughter five LA noire LA noir a-go it
was just a sparse world it was like this
is really cool to explore I want to do
more but there's nothing like yeah I
guess I'll just fast travel need to try
drive around but that's a waste of my
time so like a delicate balancing act of
content against being overwhelmed
because that was certainly how I felt a
badge and Assassin's Creed I think Black
Flag is one of those games were some
people are actually sort of more
predisposed to having long laundry list
of things to do and then some people
like myself and Justin are kind of like
intimidated by it I like things to do
Assassin's Creed
is a perfect example of a game PS i
collected everything it's one of the
last games that i 100% 'add with
complete aplomb I was so excited to 100%
it and then led that's why I getting two
Assassin's Creed I was so disappointed
that it didn't have that same field and
kept me in that same way but hey yo
Peter you're someone who definitely
plays a lot a lot of these open world
games but do you have time to collect
everything is that do I play a lot of
them but lately I've been playing a lot
of it yeahhh mister uh it's it's
difficult because you know we we sort of
work on a tight schedule here where we
have to get games done and hit deadlines
and such and I try to give as much time
as I can but it's very important that
the things that you're doing are
interesting and when they are
interesting I come back to them because
i want to i certainly don't complete
games because i feel like it's well when
it's my job to do it I do it but you
know like I don't feel like if after I
beaten a game and done the review like
well I better go back and finish stuff
because it's there waiting for me it's
no other trophy mind yeah yeah it's like
trophies it's like I want to get back
into phantom pain because the things
that I'm doing they may be similar to
something I did a while back right there
150 side missions in that game that's a
lot but they think is with every one of
those you get like a little snippet of
audio that's like where did they get the
funding for this mmm Soviets huh no they
couldn't like you don't even like it
there's always a story be that ties it
back into it I think a lot of open world
games fail to give you anything beyond a
task with a minor reward that doesn't
tie into the bigger picture of the world
and that's what's really important to me
because the difference between an open
world game in a game where you're just
given distinct levels that are kind of
disconnected is the fact that you have
free roam within a world you have the
right to observe what you wish and make
you know ops to sort of decide what this
world is all about rather than being
spoon-fed to you so blatantly and when a
game just gives you chores you're not
learning anything from those what your
three did that so beautifully like that
was a world where like I was thrown in I
loved getting more story and finding out
new things about stuff but I was also
happy to just like I'm gonna go see
what's over there I'm gonna get in a
boat and like that was one of the first
things I did once the world open up I
just gotten a boatneck traveled to the
two this next huge City and it's like
there's so much due to explore them was
intriguing it's it's almost like the
open-world genre has I come from like
two different genres you had your you're
sort of role playing games that were
large like things like you know I'm
thinking back on like old Aldo
scrolls games like dragon for things
like that which like eventually turned
into the Oblivion's of the world and the
the fallouts and scarves and one and
then he kind of just had like
traditional third-person action games
which had worlds that just got bigger so
instead of having like games like you
know maybe MDK which were like large
open world game or large open areas that
you like fought with in then instead of
them being like sort of larger linear
levels went off together they sort of
just broke them out so that you've got
your infamous and your crackdown and
stuff like that and kind of like Mad Max
like that seems like a game where it's
it's you've just got a bunch of missions
but instead of them being like one by
one they're just like one after you
they're there in an open world or far
cry for instance but then games like
ground zeroes or like The Witcher 3 that
they almost seem like they are real
worlds that they've created in and they
feel more fleshed out and to your point
it feels like instead of just having a
laundry list of missions to do your you
have more I guess agency to sort of
explore and figure out what you want to
do yourself I mean you feel like the
world isn't centered around you mmm you
know you feel like you are a part of it
and I think that that's very very
important in games like you know mad max
tries to do that like it has different
factions in it that are their own little
societies but you're always the center
of attention and obviously that's the
job of a main character but you have to
be the center of attention but you want
to feel like even if I wasn't in this
world it's still happening around well
right exactly yeah so you go into
mission in the phantom pain right and
it's not like like you're going there
because there's some important person
that's showing up whether you're there
or not that would happen and like it's
it's it's up to you to take care of that
guy because you know what's going to
happen and it's the right time to do it
you know but like Mad Max you show up
and it's go max is here you know that
kind of thing it's I don't know like
even Assassin's Creed is it which is
probably sort of threads the line
between the two in a way like that
always felt like a world that was just
going on like Grand Theft Auto like
going back as far as g j3 always kind of
felt like a world that was happening
even one and two actually they felt like
like Sam boxes that were like actually
or not sound back so they found like
real worlds that were actually happening
and then the witcher 3 is probably the
best example where like even when you
get involved [ __ ] doesn't go the way you
wanted so you don't even feel that
powerful yourself because really when
you try to do good like it's sort of you
know reality kicks in and it gets skewed
some other way it's
probably a weird example but the legend
of zelda majora's mask is a game that i
think imitates that open-world feel and
having a world that we're stuffs
happening all around you because it was
a game where you do have things you can
explore and you know things are going to
happen whether you affect them or not it
was very groundhogs day like these guys
are going to go through their day and do
their stuff but I can actually have an
effect on that and do something about it
and that changes aspects of the gangland
the way that they interact and things
that happen in the story so the
open-world genres been around now for a
while like last generation we saw sort
of like the big renaissance were like a
lot of other genres started to bleed
into it and we're now started to see
like some really superb games this year
taking advantage of it well what do you
guys think are like the sort of the main
rules of like this is what you need to
make a really truly great modern open
world game like going thread the rest of
this year into 2016 Justin what do you
think like our aspects of open world
games that we require now for a truly
wonderful game that you know you
wouldn't have had four or five years ago
in a in a crackdown I wouldn't have had
four facts I was just gonna say fishing
really what fishing I just want to be
able to sit is it tattoos is it sweet
watches is a customization I'll of
customization like things that so I'm
always torn on this like i love GTA and
like having all the different stores and
places you can explore and like giving
you a reason to go to these places but
at the same time like I like having
access to all of the customization as i
unlock it which you know that's always
kind of a weird balance just right guy a
good open world game makes you feel like
you're accomplishing something whether
you are following the main story or not
even if you're just wandering around
you're going through the world you know
you want to feel like I what I just did
was worthwhile and meaningful and I got
something cool out of it whether I was
helping a dude out in the middle of a
marsh or whether I was following the set
path and going down like here's where I
need to go in the game one of the things
that always I think I'm the type of
person who like I spend my weekends kind
of you know exploring and I like going
cycling on my own I genuinely have
always loved like exploring new places
and for me like in these games I think
the thing that really matters the most
is that it feels like a world in which
something Crazy's just around the corner
that it's it's not like you know a game
i really enjoyed which was in from the
second son that came out it was the last
year there before like look at that
look again like watch dogs like they
just feel like video game worlds and you
know exactly what's on brand the next
block it's going to be the same thing
and people on their phones whatever
we're is like a game like which are you
know for either Skyrim you kind of you
never really have that sense of you you
know you can see everything it's kind of
like you've got the blinders on I think
that sense of like wandering discovery
is maybe the most important thing my
favorite open-world game is walking
through the Tenderloin in San Francisco
yeah exactly San Francisco humor life
imitating art what about yourself either
you played a you've played to open world
games in the past week grande zev sorry
the final pain of course I'm not maxik
what what do you think are sort of
elements that are important in like a
open world game in 2015 a degree of
authenticity is needed you know but it's
not required but I think the two things
that are required you guys both already
brought up right which is feeling like
you are a part of a thing without being
the only thing that is in control and
the sense of discovery and surprise you
know like if I think if the phantom pain
was it was a more consistently like
repetitive environment and like you kind
of get the sense in the begetter you
think at the beginning like home Anand
all Afghanistan is gonna look the same
yeah I kind of oh yeah I'm like to our
I'm a six hours in I guess I me I'm kind
of thinking oh how is this what it is
then for here on ya know but nobody you
find new things and and and the same
thing happens again when you go to the
next country and its it is being in a
place that is worth exploring with
activities that are worth doing and you
know a society that's worth
participating in whether that's for
better for good or for evil mmm you know
having a pet helps too I'm having a bet
that can't die that's why fall 94 is
probably gonna be game with year 2050
also try something that's true and yeah
you got to actually horse it seems to be
the but you about you about d horse cut
his name yeah d horse Dior's East I'm
for dog or daughter diamond door I don't
don't ya dog horse [ __ ] horse right God
you got dog me to rid of the house in
fallout 4 perhaps we'll see da brooch
horses you know it is an attention to
detail that's what more open world games
need because it's the little things that
add up hmmm that's what did these Don's
for detail hotel new dollars the bikie
tails on the D and thank you so much
Peter Brad Justin hey wolf coming in and
talking a whole
about open-world video games if you've
any thoughts on what makes a great open
war game please by all means let us know
in the comment box below and that's the
show that's it they go folks before we
go I want to do a quick shout out to a
very important member of the gamespot
community sadly passed away and we found
that last week in before you all was a
name known as another user name prior
John WH 18 was a member of our forums
specifically system Wars and there are
lost chatting in that fantastic
community there it's been there for a
long time I celebrated my 10-year
anniversary as a gamespot registered
user and just last week on the
twenty-fifth of august and i get a test
the great friends that I met via that in
the blogs and everything on gamespot and
so to John's family to everyone who knew
in before you all both in the community
and in real life our thoughts are with
you guys of course and thank you for
spending as some of your life with us
John and may you rest in peace and
that's our show for this week folks
you're gonna go play some video games
today you're gonna go hit up some more
features on the side what you got going
on now I'm gonna go cry go go cry hey
man this stuff happens dark it's the way
of us I always feel like the online
communities is like a particularly
difficult sort of thing that happens
like meeting people via the Internet
often not meeting them like just grazing
and you know passing people via Twitter
and forums and stuff like that and it's
like a sort of a strange 21st century
type of type of thing but yeah oh we got
all we can do I guess is just remember
people and and continue on and I guess
keep complaining about video games and
system Wars or just did you do let's
just be good or just we go to each other
yes on the internet and in the comments
yeah so that's our show this week thanks
so much for everyone tuning in thanks so
much to medication Josh Shaw Eric Tatum
horik Tyree whatever in the back setting
up the show and thank you for watching
and thank you to our wonderful community
at gamespot of course everyone watches
on twitching YouTube as well but a
special thought everyone on the gamespot
community for keeping us doing all this
stuff and we'll see you guys next week
there's a bonus episode of lobby as well
going up on the site soon enough
thursday hopefully it's been a long week
so
okay at a time when that there's a lot
of fixing has tougher on that yeah so
make sure you check back the site to
watch that as well and we will see you
next time at Tuesday 2 p.m. pacific
right here on gamespot com adios
you